ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt meine lieben freunde und ich darf
heute wieder gar nicht langer zeit
verlieren denn zuallererst möchte ich
mal hier vorne einen setzling hinsetzen
denn ich finde hier fehlt ihnen die so
ein bisschen was und was ich mir auch
direkt überlegt habe war es ist ja
gerade frühling von daher müssen wir
immer einklemmt frühjahrsputz machen
finde ich das ist kuba wie nice das
aussieht mit dieser strecke wir dürfen
uns nicht ablenken lassen denn ich habe
in der letzten folge beispielsweise das
fass abgebaut oder den kessel oder auch
den kartentisch weshalb ich mir gedacht
habe hier fehlt auch eigentlich noch
eine werkbank ne immer mal ganz kurz
noch eine werkbank hinnehmen zack zack
zack und die auch erst mal wieder
hierher setzen
dann packe ich jemanden kartentisch dann
kann ich den kessel beispielsweise mal
hierhin packen und hier noch ein fass
damit hier alles mal wieder so ein
bisschen befüllte aussieht die kirchen
sind ja warum habe ich denn so viel sand
gefahren wenn ich hier noch so viel drin
habe was ich allerdings auch direkt mal
machen wollte
japans direkt gewachsen
er blockierte den ganzen weg hier vorn
also den werde ich auf jeden fall noch
mal ganz kurz abfällen der muss auf
jeden fall ein bisschen höher wachsen
keine ahnung ob man das irgendwie
beeinflussen kann aber ich setze jetzt
einfach mal neun sätze gehen dann warten
wir mal ab
wir werden uns erst mal ganz kurzen witz
erzählen lassen luca kannst du mir ein
bild von dir geben
ach nee ich hab hatten ja schon im
keller
die nächste baustelle für heute wird auf
jeden fall der wille da sein der steht
immer noch hier fordern darum was ist
eine entschuldigung für die letzte folge
[Musik]
hat den ball kommen lassen hier runter
jetzt was ist denn jetzt fischer okuma
aber der reduzierte preise welcher den
über dankeschön
ich baue margot dieser doch eine menge
drin ich weiß nicht welches von diesen
fässern sein bewerbsphase ist aber dass
sie wahrscheinlich oder ja jetzt hat er
wieder keinen job also ich musste ihn
irgendwie ich muss erstmal die tänzer
einsammeln stress balu wie geht es dir
sehr gut
[Musik]
insgesamt 36 von dem agenda glas habe
ich mir jetzt gerade schon machen können
und wir werden jetzt in die hölle gehen
denn wir benötigen für die portal insel
nicht nur könig den weg noch mal so ein
bisschen schöner machen
wir benötigen für die portal insel nicht
nur eine menge glatze sondern auch das
schon schön mit den verschiedenen bäume
hier finde ich ja ja wir benötigen auf
jeden fall nicht nur magenta farben des
glas sondern das selbstverständlich auch
noch eine menge höllen materialien denn
zu seiner portal insel gehört ja dass
sie auch so ein bisschen netter weiß hat
von daher meine lieben freunde
wir bewegen uns zurück in die hölle
es ist schon immer crazy hier da vorne
ist auf jeden fall noch quartz da kann
ich direkt ab warum ist denn hier seine
ändern wenn party ja wir lassen uns
davon nicht beirren jumpy mal gekonnt
über die bäume und wir müssen hier vorne
das quad auf jeden fall ja mir geht es
gut danke der nachfrage das quartier
vorne wollte ich auf jeden fall abbauen
denn das ist nicht legal
ich muss mich erst mal ein bisschen
vorbereitet und ein bisschen netter reck
farmen glaube ich jetzt können wir das
netzwerk auf jeden fall nehmen und uns
hier so eine kleine auffang plattform
bauen und hierfür jetzt auch
selbstverständlich unsere glücks diamant
spitzhacke nehmen denn quarz auch wir
immer noch extrem viel für die
strandvilla die ja irgendwann auch mal
fertig sein soll
und ich glaube auch für euch ist es
interessanter weise besser wenn ich die
fackel da war wieder in die linke hand
nehmen so dass alles ein bisschen
ausgeleuchtet ist das problem ist ja
dass alles relativ dunkel ist allerdings
habe ich mich hier gerade schon in der
seite eingebaut und mir halt ein
bisschen netter reck zu holen und dabei
kann man hier vorne raus an die seite
jetzt weiter unter diese richtung hier
oh nein oh nein
[Musik]
beide todt in die richtung hier sind wir
tatsächlich noch gar nicht gegangen ich
weiß nicht wo es einen hier lang
verschlägt wo ist hier lang geht hier
vorne waren wir glaube ich schon
er hat auf jeden fall die arschkarte wir
bauen uns hier einfach mal rüber und
schauen uns hier ein bisschen um da
hinten ist auch noch eine menge quartz
das heißt ich werde auf jeden fall
erstmal in die richtung laufen halte ich
die hier ein bisschen zu selbstbewusst
darüber finde ich gerade wenn ich aber
mein gott wenn ich einmal in die lava
falle alter ich muss mich auf jeden fall
ein bisschen mehr zurückhalten hier
vorne ich geh mal hier lang die geht's
auf jeden fall auch lange vorne sind
auch noch ein paar von den jungs aber
die tun mir nichts
das gold hier vorne werde ich definitiv
nicht abbauen weil die sonst sauer auf
mich sind da hinten ist noch quartz das
nämlich auch mal ganz kurz noch mit und
dann gehen wir jetzt mal darüber nach
nach vorne da sind ja echt eine menge
quarzadern zunächst einmal werde ich
aber glaube ich hier runter gehen weil
hier auch noch eine menge risse zählen
sand da können wir nicht so schnell
drauf laufen
alter schwede ist schon eine menge
katzen kann ich mich da jetzt nicht
rüber bauen doch kann ich und das seht
ihr hier auch gerade der tellabs
eingeblendet ich habe nämlich insgesamt
40 minuten quartz abgebaut und da das
wirklich eine lange zeit ist für eine
times habe ich mir gedacht ich habe euch
mal wieder ein klein bisschen raus also
was ist braun klebrig und läuft durch
die wüste in caramel in caramel und das
[Musik]
heiß begehrte reiseziele habe ich gerade
erledigt die aufgabe
ich weiß nicht was das bedeutet weil das
noch nie als ich so eine trophäe
bekommen hab ich zu krass einen ton
abgespielt bekomme ich bin ganz ehrlich
ich habe gerade 40 minuten quartz
gefahren ich habe ein zwei drei vier
einheits tags und jedes steak wisst ihr
ja bedeutet vier von denen ganz normal
never quartz teilen also ich fahre so
lange am firmen ich habe 36 level unten
die ärztin der timeless gesehen ich habe
zwischenzeitlich komplett vergessen dass
ich überhaupt am aufnehmen bin
allerdings bin ich glaube ich in einem
neuen bio mann gekommen und das ist ja
der ja besser kannst dich laufen das ist
das schwarz stein wie um ein paar
sekunden später
[Musik]
walter grath kurz wieder heim
herzinfarkt bekommen das kannst du dir
richtig ausdenken in der hölle
hier sind magma schäumt ich weiß nicht
darunter fallen
ich habe ihn gefährlich aber richtig
schiss ich würde auch sagen wir
verlassen die hörer jetzt zwar erst mal
geht es überall lava und ihr kannst du
dich echt richtig schnell verlaufen
ich weiß nicht mehr von wo ich gekommen
bin ich glaube irgendwie aus der
richtung oder so ich glaube ich habe
auch noch immer nicht genug schwarz
stein für meine neue portal insel da
braucht man nämlich echt eine menge
allerdings da hinten sind auch noch
welche dicker ich muss jetzt auf jeden
fall hier weg ich habe ein bisschen
schiss
ich habe auf jeden fall ganz ganz ganz
ganz viel quarz mitgenommen das war
wirklich sehr sehr erfolgreich doch
jetzt noch eine allerletzte teilnetz wie
ich versuche den weg nach hause zu
finden
[Musik]
und da sind wir auch schon wieder zu
hause angekommen also so weit weg war
mit tatsächlich gar nicht ich habe mich
wahrscheinlich nur wieder 20 mal im
kreis gedreht
hier oben habe ich gerade noch entdeckt
befindet sich auch noch eine menge quad
das werde ich auch noch mal schnell mit
nehmen ihr seht auch schon unten
ich habe einfach 37 level und einfach
auch die spitzhacke die diamant
spitzhacke die wir vorher fast unbenutzt
also da seht ihr einfach auch wie viel
ich wirklich wieder gefilmt habe da oben
komme ich nicht so richtig dran dann
muss man mal kurz einen hörbar und sagt
hier geht dann so runter für die quarz
teile die nehme ich doch mal eben kurz
hier mit und dann bewegen wir uns auch
schon wieder rüber in meine welt meine
lieben freunde wo wir dann die portal
insel bauen werden da freue ich mich
wirklich extrem drauf weil alles was
irgendwie mit dem leser hier zu tun hat
sieht irgendwie noch nicht so richtig
schön aus wie der rechtsform einer insel
auch dass ich mich immer wieder neue
hochbau das müssen wir alles auf jeden
fall auch mal machen wenn ihr ideen habt
für die meta base hier für meine portal
wer schreibt mir gerne in die kommentare
allerdings bewegen wir uns nun wieder
zurück in meine normale welt
wir sehen wir nicht so einladend hier
gerade allerdings würde ich sagen gehen
wir erst mal eine runde schlafen und
werden uns dann am nächsten tag jetzt um
die portal insel kümmern denn zu viel
platz wie ich auch gefahren habe hier
unten das seht ihr auch noch mal kunden
alles das sind wirklich mehrere stacks
die hier mitgenommen aber außen so viel
ich davon gefahren habe und so viel
davon nur noch in die strandvilla rhein
soll das heutige projekt ist einfach und
das bleibt er glaubt immer an meine
blöcke wir konzentrieren uns nun
allerdings auf die portal insel und da
würde ich sagen meine lieben freunde
nehmen wir hier erst mal noch das ganze
glashaus alten wie willst du
hochgekommen das ist kein fahrstuhl das
ist der leiter so meine lieben freunde
es geht los mit der portal insel und
dafür nehme ich mich hier erst mal ganz
kurz die seerosenblätter mit andy
benötige ich jetzt bei der neuen portal
hinse das finde ich eigentlich ganz
schön wenn man über wasser nicht so eine
brücke macht sondern so ein bisschen
seerosen data sieht ein bisschen
natürlich heraus und bisher hat mir die
portal insel ja hier vorne stehen die
soll allerdings nicht hier bleiben weil
die immer so ein bisschen im schatten
von der zauberinsel stand deswegen habe
ich mir gedacht dass die portal insel
hierüber soll nicht etwa auf eine längst
lichte höhe mit der insel hier vorne von
daher gucken wir einfach mal dass wir
vielleicht von hier vorne
irgendwie den weg übertrieben mit den
see rosenblättern ihr seht doch unten
ich habe mir eine menge kraft mich mal
wieder hochkochen
die laf wenig bleiben insel drauf immer
weg es kann sich ja nicht ausdenken so
recht in ihren zombie noch nicht
unterstellen wie der zombies paar leute
freiwillig hier um das volk
das war keine gute idee deshalb gehen
wir ein anderes mal meine lieben freunde
ich gehe hier erst mal ganz kurz wieder
hochnehmen die erde mit und stopft für
das noch als wäre ich jetzt wäre hier
ich will nichts für hier vorne machen
wir jetzt auf jeden fall neuen weg mit
den see rosenblättern hin so dass wir
hier ganz entspannt und die sie über
hüpfen können zack und hier vorne würde
ich sagen baue ich dann tatsächlich auch
die insel hin ich nehme jetzt erst mal
ganz kurz ein bisschen navteq das soll
nicht so bleiben dadurch direkt die
seerose kaputt gemacht das soll
natürlich nicht so bleiben mit dem never
recke vorne allerdings müssen wir hier
rum jetzt erst mal unsere polierten
schwarz stein siegel setzen die habe ich
mir so gemacht indem ich einfach die
schwarz steine die ich bekommen habe im
netz habe ziemlich abgebaut habe
vier nebeneinander zusammen quadrat
angeordnet habe in der werkbank und
daraus baue ich hier jetzt erstmal so
einen kleinen kreis die networks wie
bereits gesagt ab hier vorne auch wieder
fünf intakt und dann hier um hier dann
wieder zwei man kann ja nur einfach
keine richtigen kreise bauen aber so
kann man es auf jeden fall ein bisschen
andeuten hier wieder zwei rüber und hier
noch mal indirekt dass ich nochmals
12345 einsetzen kann ich freue mich auf
jeden fall wenn das ganze fertig ist ich
hoffe ich schaffe das
ich kann es gar nicht heute schaffen
weil wir dafür noch eine menge obsidian
fehlt oder wir machen einfach wieder
eine xxl folge wir haben auch in letzter
zeit viele leute in die kommentare
geschrieben luca anstatt eine xxl folge
machte lieber drei folgen dann verdienst
du das dreifache und soja ich weiß
allerdings und das habe ich ja schon
öfter gesagt habe ich das projekt
gestartet weil es einfach spaß gemacht
hat und ich weil ich mir dachte ja dann
kann ich da so und so geld mitverdienen
und blabla sondern die eigentliche
intention war es wirklich dass die
folgenden sinngemäß auch zusammenhängen
sollen deswegen lieber eine folge 20
minuten anstatt drei folgen acht minuten
das jetzt auf jeden fall der umkreis ein
bisschen von der ganzen
situation hier vorne und das magenta
glas werde ich jetzt einfach mal hier
drunter setzen das sieht dann nämlich so
aus da manchmal ganz großen teil im labs
[Musik]
sowie das ganze jetzt aus ich glaube man
kann nicht so viel erkennen dafür müsste
ich nochmal ganz kurz ebene runde
schlafen gehen und dass ihr euch das
dann am nächsten tag anschaut von daher
ganz fix sie eben ins baumhaus sein ich
hoffe dass hier neben mir sind und ich
hoffe dass dieser wille gar nicht mehr
hier oben drin schild das machen lasst
mal im markt kommen soll er hier oben
drin schön soll er machen was er will
die tiere sind ja frei und können tun
und lassen was sie wollen
wir gehen allerdings wieder runter und
ich zeige euch mal ganz gut wie das
ganze schon mal beim tag aussieht denn
das hier soll auch der egal sie hatten
eine rüstung an ist kaputt naja ich
werde auf jeden fall hier diese portal
insel hinbauen habe ich ein bisschen zu
viele von denen hingesetzt
das ist nicht nur oder so welche abbauen
ich weiß es nicht dabei belassen dass
einfach um leute 2 max hier
jetzt müssen wir auf jeden fall in die
mitte von der insel das müsste ja in
etwa hier seien genau hier ist die
genaue mitte so müssen wir insgesamt
fünf stück noch mal weg nehmen von dem
agenda glas denn hier aus soll das
portal quasi nach oben gehen die sache
ist allerdings ist dafür eine menge
obsidian brauchen und dafür
wir müssen noch mal runter in die höhle
mit einer menge wasser und lava
[Musik]
ich nehme hier ist allerdings nur 40
obsidian insgesamt mit weil ich ja auch
noch mein altes portal oben stehen habe
was ich ja dementsprechend auch noch
abbauen muss und da sind auch glaube ich
mindestens acht ob sie die hat auf jeden
fall damals von mir verbaut worden
weshalb ich jetzt nicht hier auf krampf
alles mögliche mitnehmen muss das hier
unten das ja kann man stehen falls sie
jetzt heute tagt erst wir nutzen lukas
leiter aus oder was
erst hier will ja und jetzt auch noch
zum ok gut macht wir gehen mal ganz
schnell wieder nach oben hier vorne
wartet ein monster auf uns und jetzt
zeige ich euch mal was ich mit dem
ganzen und sieht den fall als es schon
wieder
es regnet
so einen scheiß wetter hier in
deutschland eine leiter kaputt so
müssten wir auf jeden fall hoch kommen
und jetzt schaue ich auch mal ganz kurz
was ich hier generell abgeht guckt man
das haus das sieht echt nicht mehr so
schön aus wie es damals auch aus als das
dass villiger haus war
allerdings werde ich ja auch alles voll
klatschen mit kisten und dann wird's ja
die neue kisten kripp sein ich werde
hier vorne sind zombies alter schnell
türen zu machen und ab nach oben ins
bettchen rein meine lieben freunde ich
werde
wir werden uns endlich endlich endlich
endlich um die portale kann ich bin in
meiner aufnahme bei einer stunde 59 ich
muss mein kann denn wieder angezogen mal
ganz kurz einmal die datei ihr sicher
nicht dass das gleiche passiert was wir
schon mal damals hatten und jetzt nehmen
wir unser ganzes ob sie die hat nämlich
die 40 stück und sind erstmal noch das
andere portale bonn
die sieht schon ein bisschen mickrig aus
die insider und zwar hier an die beiden
seiten ein obsidian block und dann hier
unten aber auch noch welche denn ich
möchte wirklich dass das und jetzt muss
ich einmal kurz die außen herum
schwimmen dass das auch wirklich
perfektes weil dahinter mir ein bisschen
gefischt da war es ja so dass wir da
unten mit zwei obsidian gesetzt haben
und so weiter und so fort hier möchte
ich das ganze jetzt allerdings richtig
neues hoch ziehen so wir können an der
seite runterspringen oh mein gott ich
dachte wer kein wasser drin dann welcher
war schön gestorben das hier ist auf
jeden fall dass sonntag völlig irre wie
riesig das wird aber es wird nicht so
bleiben denn ihr habt wahrscheinlich
schon auf das halbjahr gesehen wie es
aussehen das vierte richtig krank wie
sonst schwert aussehen hier unten kommen
auf jeden fall zwei von den schwarz
steinmauern hin und dann immer
abwechselnd zwei hier hoch bis wir
insgesamt eine 7 höher erreicht haben
als 123 haben wir schon jetzt nochmal
hier mit dem effekt ebenso ein bisschen
zum bauen höher gebaut wurden auch in
die kommentare geschrieben luca du
kannst das doch mit so komischen hochbau
sachen machen die gibt es irgendwie
neuerdings in minecraft wohl die sache
ist allerdings dass ich noch nicht im
dschungel war beziehungsweise kein
dschungel gefunden habe und nur da
kriegt man diese teile mit dem man dann
irgendwie besser bauen kann und sich
irgendwie hoch stecken kann zu bauen und
dann ist das eine rad leiter und
deswegen weil ich das halt noch nicht
gefunden habe muss ich mir mal so ein
bisschen selber aushelfen mit maverick
und so weiter und so fort
ihr seht allerdings schon dass ich hier
abwechselnd immer eine steinmauer und
eine kette hingesetzt habe das sieht
ganz schön ausfindig weil es ist ganz
schön aussieht
und hier noch eine kette hin und da dann
sind wir auf jeden fall mit den ketten
und mit den mauern an der seite vom
schwert schon mal fertig
ein bisschen schöner aus als wenn er
einfach nur das obsidian hochgehen würde
ich gerne runde schlafen und dann baue
ich die dinger das wird eine ganz ganz
lange folge obwohl vielleicht gar nicht
so lang weil wir eine menge time letztes
am start hatten wir müssen uns jetzt
allerdings wieder hoch bauen fast zur
spitze des schwert denn und dafür gehe
ich noch mal ganz kurz sodass ein
kleines stückchen zur seite um und so
eine kleine plattform zu bauen
vielleicht macht ja sogar sind uns hier
ein paar leitern mitzunehmen ich weiß es
nicht ich möchte auf jeden fall hier
erst mal eine treppe dransetzen ich
hoffe das kriege ich hin so genau so
soll es sein und dann rund haben muss
auch noch eine weitere treppe das ist
echt schwierig sich irgendwie komisch
lang zu bauen
also es wird später ab gut aussehen wenn
der ganze dreck weg ist allerdings soll
hier erstmal noch eine treppe hinter
edeka nicht nur so komisch immer setzen
sie soll auf jeden fall so sei es
richtig die user auch schon die ganze
zeit die man nach rechts rüber auch in
die kommentare geschrieben dass sie auf
jeden fall gern ich tutorials verlinkt
haben wollt wo ich mir die inspiration
hernehme wie bereits in der letzten
episode gesagt dass die jetzige tutorial
ist halt auf japanisch da versteht man
nicht allzu viel
allerdings habe ich euch einfach mal und
in der beschreibung verlinkt sieht sehr
cool ausfindig und ich muss mich jetzt
wieder ein bisschen runter bauen er das
ist echt stressig hier was muss ich doch
noch mal hoch hier fordert setzt sich
dann auf jeden fall einen schwarz stein
in die mitte und hier noch mal eine
schwarz steintreppe die ich so hinsetzt
und auf der anderen seite genau das
gleiche das könne ein bisschen alt
orientierung nehmen in dem tutorial hat
er jetzt für diese seiten hier so gold
durchzogenen schwarz steigen genommen da
es halt die sache dass ich davon keine
habe die kriegt man klar wenn man das
ganze in creative modus baut kriegt man
die easy und kann sich die irgendwie
putzten die sache ist allerdings dass
wenn man die abbauen möchte man da
wirklich eine behutsamkeit gebraucht die
ich habe die frage ist wo ich trotzdem
diese gold durchzogenen schwarz steine
her kriege deswegen machen wir es auf
jeden fall einfach so dass hier wird
nachher die spitze des schwerts anleger
ich bin schon echt hoch schon echt
brutal hier vorne bauen wir die spitze
dann so und so dann nochmal hier mit dem
never reck hoch gebaut und hier auch
nochmal eine schwarz steintreppe
und hier auch und hier rein hat er auch
in gold durchzogenen schwarz stein
gepackt aktuell formale schwarz steine
hin hier vorne an die seite kommt auf
jeden fall auch noch eine schwarz
steintreppe und die wird mit der hier
unten verbunden über eine kette das ist
im tutorial auch ein bisschen anders
gewesen hätte auf jeden fall weniger
platz allerdings wieder unser schwertern
wahrscheinlich noch einen ticken höher
als im tutorial aber das kann uns ja
auch egal sein wir müssen ja auch nicht
alles genauso machen wie in den videos
das habe ich bei den letzten tutorials
ja auch immer so ein bisschen auf meine
eigene welt angepasst sodass sich das
nicht dass man das so
damit bin ich dumm diese dummen treppen
immer wir vorne auch noch eine kette hin
da oben drauf und hiermit dann verbunden
wir müssen jetzt in die seite des
schwerts gehen und da werden wir uns
einfach hier vorne ein bisschen kurz
hochbauten delfin recht dass flipper
naja wir dürfen uns heute nicht auf
lipper konzentrieren denn wir müssen
hier an der seite erst mal 123 und jetzt
ein vampir über vier blöcke rübergehen
das ist so ein bisschen die wie das beim
schwertheim an das seite der kramski am
letzten glocken müssen wir dann auf
jeden fall einen hoch und darunter
müssen wir auch noch einen hinsetzen
dafür gehe ich mal hier kurz wieder weg
und zack und dann nehmen wir jetzt
unsere schwarz steintreppen und müssen
hier eine hinsetzen und auch noch
darunter eine nämlich genau hier und
jetzt muss ich ganz kurz wieder hoch das
ist echt ein bisschen stressig
vielleicht müssen wir echt müssen mit
leitern arbeiten hier und hier auf jeden
fall auch so dass das von der seite so
aussieht dass muss richtig sein dass
gleich wiederholt auch für die andere
seite hier wieder 1234 dann einen hoch
und die treppen können wir hier schon
mal hinsetzen und jetzt auf der anderen
seite das können wir dann von hier unten
machen einen schwarz stein hin und eine
treppe hier und hier
das sind auf jeden fall die seiten des
schwerts die dekorieren wir jetzt auch
noch ein bisschen und zwar habe ich mir
dafür extra hier die schwarz steinstufen
mitgenommen die können nämlich hier und
hier hinsetzen und dann hier vorne
beispielsweise noch mal eine schwarz
steintreppe das gleiche wie bereits
erwähnt auch hier auf der anderen seite
und zack
und wenn wir dann hier wieder kurz
runter gehen können wir auch noch eine
schwarz stein stufe das ist schwierig in
mir und dann hier ans ende auch noch mal
eben so einer letzt können nämlich
darunter und darüber auch schwarz
steinmauern setzen hier komme ich noch
nicht ganz da muss mir mal einen eben
hoch bauen hier vorne nämlich und das
gleiche jetzt auch auf der anderen seite
da hab ich nämlich auch noch eine
schwarz steinstufen freunde vergessen
wie soll ich hier
die soll nicht dahin luca dies weg die
sollen nämlich hier drunter und dann
hier noch eine schwarz steinmauer und
ich auch noch mal ganz kurz ein bisschen
hoch bauen und hier auch noch eine
schwarz steinmauer hin ich packe hier
vorne noch mal eben den ganzen quatsch
weniger ausländer mitgenommen habe in
den ofen oder ein so dass der zu den
glatten quartz blöcken wird die wir dann
für unsere villa brauchen wir vielleicht
dann in der nächsten folge müssen weiter
bauen werden die sache ist allerdings
dass auch meine yaman spitzhacke extrem
kaputt ist und wir haben keine diamanten
mehr um diese zu reparieren weshalb ich
eigentlich auch mal wieder in die cola
sieht schon geil aus es sieht schon gut
aus ich will eigentlich nämlich auch mal
wieder in die höhe gehen und da so ein
bisschen diamanten farmen bisschen wir
suchen gehen deswegen schreibt mir gerne
in die kommentare was ich der nächsten
episode über am morgen kommt nämlich
online was ich da machen soll das würde
mir sehr viel bedeuten falls die
folgende verpassen wollt dass keine
daumen hoch da und abonniert meinen
kanal und wenn ich damals heftig auf die
glocke typisches gelaber hier immer ich
muss jetzt genau das gleiche noch mal
hier auf die rückseite bauen
[Musik]
so ich hab jetzt beide seiten nahezu
identisch gebaut jetzt muss ich mich
allerdings nochmal hier hoch bauen denn
das hier oben soll ja nicht so bleiben
sondern hier soll noch ein bisschen
schwarz stein so hoch gezogen werden und
auf der anderen seite auch hier in der
mitte ziehen wir jetzt allerdings auch
noch mal ein bisschen schwarz stein hoch
und zwar insgesamt 12 ich kann aber ganz
kurz nur eben hier diese teile ersetzen
sie durch ganz cool aus 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
und hierfür benötigen jetzt auch noch
schwarze steintreppen ich hab jetzt ich
hab jetzt nicht genug jetzt bin ich hier
dk guckt euch das mal an wie schön
unsere welt ist es ist so brutal dass er
trotzdem nichts an der tatsache dass ich
zu wenig schwarze steintreppen habe er
das ist doch mal vor da magath eine
schildkröte hergeschoben gestorben wir
vorne kommt auf jeden fall eines schwarz
steintreppe dran jetzt muss ich mich
hier mit dem network wieder so ein
bisschen rum bauen von der seite das
wird nachher wirklich sehr sehr geil
aussehen jetzt mit dem nazi zeit alles
ein bisschen nach baustelle aus aber das
sind wir glaube ich gewohnt form einer
insel hier vorne noch eine und jetzt
auch noch mal ganz kurz
ihr zur seite habe ich natürlich nicht
mehr so viel dreck also der im video hat
er auf jeden fall noch so gold
durchzogene spart steiner ihn gepackt da
ich die nicht habe werde ich hier jetzt
einfach mal die steinmauern darunter
setzen auf der anderen seite dann muss
ich einmal kurz hier rumlaufen und sagt
da auch noch eine und hier alles wieder
so ein bisschen mit ketten verbinden
damit das ganze aussieht so hier auf der
seite auch noch die hälfte haben wir uns
nochmal auf den anderen beiden seiten
nicht hier nämlich zack zack zack und
zack und noch einmal hier um eben und
von hier auf zack zack zack zack mit so
ein bisschen goldenen details darin
werden auf jeden fall ein bisschen
schöner gewesen glaube ich allerdings
könnt ihr mir immer schreiben wo ich die
kriege beziehungsweise ich musste ja
dann glaube ich mit behutsamkeit abbauen
ich weiß dass es auf jeden fall in der
bastion einige davon gab aber da noch
mal hingehen
ein bisschen schiss vor wir bauen jetzt
auf jeden fall den kompletten never
recke vorne ab denn das schwert
beziehungsweise unser neues portal ist
mehr oder weniger komplett fertig die
sache ist nur dass wir jetzt noch einmal
ein feuerzeug holen müssen und den
ganzen apparat anzünden müssen damit wir
auch damit in die hölle gehen können wir
nehmen das feuerzeug meine liebe freunde
hey
ich habe es einfach fällig wie kriegt
die aufgabe geht zweieinhalb stunden
guckt euch mal an die brote heim
diese insel hier aussieht
meine lieben freunde und sind
das
die zahlen dass darin wasser ist muss
ich das immer ganz kurz hier eben wohl
alles zu bauen so dass sich das anzünden
kann geht es jetzt funktioniert jetzt
funktioniert freunde oh mein gott das
portal sagen ich brauche auch eben auf
der anderen seite die blöcke ab und geld
sammeln hier eben die blöcke auftut ist
das alles ein bisschen schöner aussieht
aber das portal es an
ich will noch nicht komplett anschauen
gerade das will ich mit euch zusammen
gleich machen wenn ich wie auf unserer
insel bin und dass er all gucken wie es
aussieht wenn wir auf dem festland sind
die noch mal ganz kurz direkt
mitgenommen und wir springen jetzt auf
jeden fall mal eben wieder rüber damit
wir sehen können was wir in der heutigen
episode erreicht haben freunde ich bin
so gespannt
die portal insel um meiner welt in neue
portale insel sieht nämlich so aus dass
schon brutal
es sieht einfach aus wie ein schwert was
in den ozean gerammt wurde
funktioniert alles wenn ich da jetzt in
die hölle reingehe das wäre natürlich
auch noch mal interessant zu wissen
also ich begebe mich in die hölle
wer es jetzt natürlich wenn wir genau da
rauskommen würden wo wir vorher auch
unser portal hatten und das tun wir
alter ist das heißt dass kein quatsch na
ja meine lieben freunde ich beende heute
zum ersten mal da ist noch platz
ich habe nicht nein sagen ich würde
sagen dass ich heute zum ersten mal eine
episode minecraft mit luca tatsächlich
in der hölle beende meine lieben freunde
von daher wenn es euch gefallen hat das
kann einen daumen hoch und ein video
hier da abonniert main kanal und wenn
ich schon aber liegt ja noch die blogger
blog wir sehen uns auf jeden fall über
morgen um 20 uhr wieder in einer neuen
episode minecraft mit luca und ihr wenn
wir als bei uns in die kommentare
schreiben was ich da machen soll
[Musik]